so i'm about to jump on a zoom with
um a woman who spotted the drew band
and i can't thank our producer jessica
yankonnis enough
for spotting her i cannot tell you how
profound
and cool and amazing this human being is
on our way back to the house we uh live
up here
i saw the van and i was like hashtag
drew van impe what is a drew van
and then i looked at the hashtag and i
was like oh my gosh
it's true very well i was like what if
that's drew barrymore we have to go back
and my husband's like what
i was like it might be who knows so we
drove back and then i saw them walking
around i'm like hey
so tell me about the van
so it was a really nice couple and they
told me how they had came from
california they're going up to new york
and they're stopping at these different
stops and whatnot and they're like you
wanna do a shout out i'm like yeah i
want to do a shout out
hi rebecca i drew
oh my gosh now rebecca
i have to say i was reading about your
life
and i'm so glad that you spotted the
drew van and will you just tell us a
little bit about yourself rebecca
it was a difficult childhood i was
in foster care i grew up i
was on my own at a very early young age
i decided to go in the military because
it would
be a safe place i could learn a career
and i plan on doing that forever
unfortunately i did have cervical cancer
so i was not able to stay in for life
but i'm good how did you deal
and how old were you when you found out
you had cervical cancer for the first
time
when i found out about the cervical
cancer i was while i was actually on a
deployment
um i was in the texas army national
guard and we were down on the border
and that's when i found out and then i
had it again later on in my adult life
and it was the same thing we just had to
go through surgery and get rid of
everything
and for anyone else that's going through
it
just stay positive and make the most of
every moment you have
even if you don't have cancer i'm big
into learning things or trying something
that i haven't done before
because i'm 36 and i'm just like
there's so much there's so much to life
i want to do it all and i don't know how
much time i have so i just want to do it
all
you know we were driving through the
ozarks i saw some guy fly fishing and it
looked like he was like ribbing dancing
like it was the weirdest
i was like what is he doing that's
that's weird that's not boring like
fishing like that looks fun
i want to go do that so i tried it out
and
fell in love with it and now i just want
to encourage other people to be
new at something like i'm going to start
working with foster cares
and helping them learn how to fly fish
through the mayfly project
which is huge because i feel like if you
have been through the foster care system
or even if you had a rough childhood
if you can stop the cycle for someone
else or if you can be there for
someone else you have no idea the impact
you may have on that person's life and
it will be a ripple effect
okay what is your advice for people who
want to
go after learning a skill a hobby
realizing a dream do it
don't talk yourself out of stuff just
get out there and experience life while
you can while you have your health while
you have your time because you won't get
those
later on in life you are so rad
i don't know if you know flower beauty i
just want to send you a bunch of care
package stuff but
really most importantly i'd like to make
a date in the future with you rebecca
yes
i would love that we would have so much
like i organically
authentically know we would connect and
have so much fun
your perspective is in a profound place
really and truly i'm so glad that i got
to meet
you
you